Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
July 9th,
2017 what's going on?
How are Ya?
How's it going?
Oh,
Billy's voice is coming back.
It's coming back.
You know,
I've been drinking my old throat coat tea there.
Right.
But Evans,
some fucking [inaudible] the halls menthyl lip this.
MMM.
You know,
just,
you know,
try not to yell at people in Traffic.
Trying to meditate,
trying to learn about patients.
Oh,
that guy cut me off.
if I get upset,
that's my fault.
According to to the fucking meditation guy on headspace.
It's,
he tries to chuckle through blaming me for other people's continuous.
That's a challenge.
That's a challenge to try to remain focused.
Yeah.
What kind of a fucking guy,
you know as you're sitting there trying to get into a zone is telling you that
things are your fault.
I know we chuckles along.
I know he's probably right.
Why?
Why should I have expectations when I'm on the highways of La that somebody
isn't going to pass me doing 90 on the right while somebody's in the left lane's
doing with 35 and I'm in the middle,
like,
you know,
and I'm in the middle.
I'm the victim.
I'm the guy driving perfectly.
I never pass people on the right bull shit.
Every once in awhile I do.
I tried to be cognizant.
Um,
I don't even know what,
I have so much shit to talk about.
I mean,
I always talk,
but I mean,
I actually have shit to talk about and by the way,
shout out to that fucking lunatic who listened to my whole fucking give the oil
man the son.
And he took it seriously.
Like he's trying to debunk my theory,
you know?
He's like,
oh goodness.
Uh,
well did you ever take about 3.4 billion cars out there who will do both
least?
That's the way I read it.
That's the way you sounded in my head and I just wrote him back,
was like,
dude,
how many f bombs did I drop during the priests?
The presentation of that theory.
Why you acting like you went to a Ted talk?
Yeah.
Was I liked the one person you felt smarter than on the Internet.
It's like,
Oh,
here's my opportunity to be like,
oh fucking,
it's a classic Internet.
The way you dive into a debate.
Oh,
maybe try this next time.
Okay.
Everybody coming at you like they have like these like just a bunch of awards up
on the wall behind him,
you know,
as opposed to you,
you know what,
whatever you,
what do you got to do?
What,
what Hacky fucking posters do you have on your wall?
Huh?
Okay.
What's a hacky poster for the,
for the millennials?
When was growing up,
you had to have the Farrah Fawcett poster.
Um,
I don't know,
a Fonzie poster or some shit like that.
It was,
you know,
it was the 70s when I was still in the posters.
Um,
I don't want to talk about you.
What I'm doing is I'm talking to you guys on trying to get fucking comfortable
on this goddamn couch.
We bought one of these fucking pullout couches and Kate's,
we have guests.
What once every three years,
someone's going to stop by here for Thanksgiving.
Yeah.
Because his fucking wife had enough with them.
So instead I gotta be on this thing that's not a couch and not a bad,
oh,
it looks fluffy.
Oh,
we've looks comfortable,
but looks are deceiving.
So anyways,
I,
um,
I've been back in the writers' room.
I'm back in the Writers' room.
F F is for family.
We're knocking out a episode one.
We got our first table read on Thursday,
and then,
um,
I'm actually gonna have to do a couple of table reads over the phone because I
got some acting work,
um,
in New York City.
And a spoiler alert,
they're rebooting sex in the city except this time they're doing it with guys.
And guess who gets to play?
Samantha?
I don't know.
What's the Cynthia Nixon,
whoever the redhead is.
All right,
I'm going to wear the short little wig.
All right?
And I'm going to be the smart girl of the fellas.
That's what's going to happen.
It's Kinda like that John Travolta movie,
hogs,
whatever the fuck it was called,
where they rode around on motorcycles.
You know,
I hate that those movies are hits.
It just reminds me of the sadness that most people live in,
that they can relate to that movie.
Like,
oh,
wouldn't it be awesome if we could still go out and do fun stuff?
I don't know why you can't.
I don't know why my voice still cracks at 49 years of age.
Why can't you continue to do fun shit?
Yeah.
Two reasons.
One,
you're exaggerating your ear.
Importance as a parent.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
And ability to,
that's the most important role you live.
I know,
I know it's important,
but the fact that you think you've got to fucking be there 24 seven staring at
your kid and you can't just sneak down the street,
you know,
for fucking 90 minutes during the day.
Like some,
what the fuck is going to happen to your kid knows not how fragile.
Yeah.
A mindset is your family in that,
God forbid you go down the street for 90 minutes,
you know,
figure 20 minute drive,
20 minute back,
you've got a shower after whatever the fuck you do,
right?
You go to your rock climbing at one of those rock climbing gyms.
You know,
you take your talc out,
your little talc,
fanny pack,
whatever the fuck it is you do.
Yeah.
When in your head you're going up mount Everest cause that's all you got.
That's all you've got.
You can't go all the way over there and walk by dead people in sleeping bags
while you got a family of family baggage do.
You can't do that.
Right?
You can't fucking do that.
So you've got to go down the fucking rock wall.
Okay?
People either over exaggerate the importance of being a Goddamn parent or they
fucking,
they're afraid of their wife.
Just say,
look,
I need to go do this.
I'll be back in 90 minutes just and then just go do it.
What is she going to do?
Tackle you on the way to your car?
The words she can do is just be meanwhile,
while the where she can do is divorce you and take all your shit.
You know,
who's kidding,
who,
um,
whatever.
You know what I mean?
You've got to every once in a while why
we steal away like fucking every two,
three days.
You can't just go down the street and just fucking do something.
Um,
I'm saying this because I have a tremendous amount of guilt because,
uh,
I came home from work,
right?
And,
um,
you know,
I make sure I,
I don't work as much as I did last year before I became a parent before I became
the most important person in the world too,
for me.
Um,
so I,
I come home like a couple hours earlier than I did last year,
right?
So I can take my daughter for a walk around the block.
We're going to walk around.
Right?
That's what I do.
Okay.
See a day I'm driving to work,
no drive to work.
I dropped my car off to get serviced.
Right?
I got the old truck I'm driving now.
I can either go right to fucking work or it'd be like 10 15 minutes early or I
can swing by my house and hang with my daughter who just woke up.
So obviously no fucking brainer.
I do that.
I hang out with them for 10 minutes.
I have a great fucking time and then I leave and I drive to work feeling like a
great dad,
feeling great that I did that.
I got my priorities straight,
right?
I'm going to raise a,
a great citizen for this wonderful land that everybody else is jealous of.
That's why they don't like us around the world.
It has nothing to do with our foreign policy.
I'm so sick of that excuse.
Okay,
just admit it.
You like our blue jeans.
You liked that we feed cows to other cows,
right?
You like that you,
you know,
you like it.
You're over there in Europe,
urine,
Asia,
wherever you are,
you're all fucking jammed up.
Everybody had fucking driving cars on cow paths or there's like 90,000
skyscrapers like over in fucking Asia.
Jesus Christ.
Hong Kong is the most astounding fucking the,
I didn't realize there was that much concrete in the fucking world.
They had clusters of Manhattan skyline just parked all around that place.
It was just never fuck it ended.
Um,
I would love to meet the Donald of Hong Kong talking about how he has the
greatest skyscraper ever.
Um,
but anyways,
so I come home and I'm like,
all right,
this is great.
I still have 10 minutes this morning I'm coming on,
I'm going to get the hang,
go for this,
walk around the block and I walk into my house.
All right.
And I noticed it's hard to open the door.
I can't open it all the way.
And I look around the corner and what do I see?
I see like five giant fucking boxes and then I see an even bigger box across the
room and they all say Gretsch drums on them.
My drum kit arrived.
I couldn't fuck it.
I was so convinced that I was like,
Murphy's law.
The second I go to New York for two fucking weeks,
uh,
that fucking drum kit's going to come.
There's going to be some nose picking jackass delivering it and he's just gonna
fucking leave it on the front porch and some asshole's going to take it.
Um,
but for once,
you know,
life worked out right.
I showed up.
It's there.
It is there.
I don't think I've ever been so fucking excited in my adult life ever.
So the drum kit came at it,
spent literally,
it was as far as when I saw it and I don't even think it's about 12 hours in my
house.
Boom,
right over to the roads.
So space and uh,
unpacked it in each block.
She on pact is a box within,
in it,
right?
You open that box up and then there's the drum and then this,
this little card,
right?
Like a birthday card from Gretsch drums and it says that great Gretsch sound and
it's written in a,
that writing that millennials can't read,
whatever the fuck you call it.
We call it writing versus printing cursive is what they call it.
Maybe that's why millennials don't like it,
you know,
cause you know,
Kurt,
I don't want to curse.
I don't want to offend anybody,
I'm going to print.
Um,
or maybe they were on computers all day bill and they just don't see it anymore.
All right,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
Whatever.
Maybe just an old guy bill and you just trashing younger people cause they're
younger than you and they're still in the prime of though.
Hey,
you know,
getting video of a point maybe.
Okay.
So,
um,
by load up my truck,
I drive over the place but 20 minutes down fucking straight.
And I started taking these things out of the box and um,
the absolutely fucking gorgeous is a couple of pieces of hardware that I need to
get,
but I am going,
I'm going to tweet a fucking picture of that thing.
Um,
probably Monday,
tomorrow I'm going to go over and pick up the last couple of pieces of hardware
that I need.
They are fucking gorgeous and I don't give a shit what you are you like those
looks like you fucking,
I don't give a fuck what you think of the color.
I love him.
So,
um,
I am,
I am just over the fucking world.
I can't fucking believe Gabley best thing I ever did.
As I got rid of that old fucking Ludwig and went out and bought the kit that I
wanted,
I can't fucking wait to go over there.
But now I have this crushing fucking guilt.
You know,
being a dangle.
You should be with your daughter right now.
It's like I can't,
and I'm fucking yelling at myself as I'm driving over there.
I can't fucking go to nau for fucking 90 minutes.
Not even 90.
I play for an hour.
20 bag 20.
Oh,
that's an hour and 40 fucking minutes.
Oh Shit.
That's more,
that's a hundred minutes of Jesus.
All right.
So I'm the worst fucking dead ever.
What do you want for me?
Keeps me in a good mood.
Um,
anyways,
they came and,
um,
I'm going over there today.
Uh,
my drum teacher,
he's gonna fucking tune them up.
Um,
I got him sound and halfway decent,
but,
uh,
I'm just a comedian.
This guy's a pro.
So these things are going to sound like,
fuck,
I don't know what they're going to sound like,
but uh,
I can't fucking wait.
I'm so God damn excited.
And um,
I got,
oh Jesus,
my stomach's growling.
Yeah,
I got to fucking,
I got my symbols.
I got the whole fucking thing that,
you know how nicely this is,
how nice the setup is.
I'm afraid to show it to my wife.
That's how nice it is.
You know that Shit,
you know when you do something like that and then your wife just looks at it and
she's just kinda quiet,
doesn't say anything and it's just,
this is all they do.
They just go,
Huh.
And you're like,
oh fuck.
How much did that,
how much?
That noise right there.
How much is that going to cost me?
You know,
all I did was buy a set of drums.
there's their fucking shit.
Well,
what's she going to go get?
I thought this would be fair.
Um,
maybe I'm just paranoid.
So anyways,
I want to thank the Gretsch Drum Company for fucking making the greatest goddamn
drums.
I've have the most beautiful fucking drums I've ever seen in my life.
It packing them up.
So that wasn't an,
it wasn't a even even a,
a piece of dust on them.
Absolutely gorgeous.
And I'm going to go over there today and I'm going to play cause I'm doing the
goddamn comedy jam,
the fucking two or three year anniversary.
I've lost track at this point.
I think it's the two year anniversary.
What did it start in 14 or 15?
Maybe 14.
No.
Started in 15,
the two year anniversary.
And um,
I'm going to be singing one song even though I can't sing and then I'm going to
be sitting in on drums for the encore and uh,
no,
I am not bringing my kid over.
I'm not bringing it over cause uh,
I don't have any cases.
Plus I would be fucking losing my mind that something bad was gonna happen to
him.
So that's it.
Um,
all right.
So there you go.
That's what I have to look forward to.
Um,
anyways,
so where do,
I didn't know what to fucking start here.
See if I can keep my happiness and my drum kit as I talk about this next thing.
I saw two of the most fucked up things
as far as,
uh,
just that have you no shame,
you know,
and I'm a piece of shit.
So for me to think that,
you know,
yeah,
I was watching,
uh,
some fucking clip.
Yeah.
Trashing Dr Phil and I never saw this,
I didn't realize this,
I guess like a year ago or two years ago,
you know that actress Shelley Duvall,
who crushed it in the shining?
Well,
she's in her sixties now and I guess she's having,
I don't know what she's having,
she's having some sort of mental issue.
I don't know what it is.
Okay.
But she's old and she needs medical help.
That scumbag.
Dr Phil,
who I called it the second I saw that guy,
I called it,
I,
I was at,
that guy looks like a fucking crooked cop.
The second I saw him,
I was like,
that guy looks like he planned a fucking gun on you.
You know,
he fucking shoot you over some routine fucking traffic stop.
And he pulled out and he'd do that to a white person.
That's how fucking nuts this guy is,
right?
He's not your standard,
you know,
bad cop going after minorities.
This guy would do it.
This guy's like a c as a serial killer.
Look,
doesn't he?
Um,
anyways,
that piece of Shit fucking interviewed Shelley Duvall and talk to her is if he
was trying to help her and she was saying all of this stuff about how Robin
Williams was still alive and fucking,
you know,
the earth is flat and just all kinds of stuff like that where it's clearly like,
oh my God,
all right,
shut off the camera,
shut off the cameras,
come on,
let's not do this to her.
And he's sitting there talking to her lie.
So he like,
he's going to try to help her.
Scilog you think that a Robin Williams is still alive?
Okay.
Um,
I think you need,
like he's,
he was acting the entire fucking time.
Like he was trying to help her rather than completely exploiting this famous
actress who's now in like,
you know,
this mental condition.
It's just fun.
It was,
I don't know.
How do,
how do you still sit down and watch that guy's fucking show?
Fuck that guy and everything.
He's fucking connected to
Jesus.
You don't have enough fucking money.
Get can't.
You don't drag enough fucking penniless people onto your fucking show.
You don't have enough honey booboo.
People comment on your fucking show.
You got to do that.
Yeah,
Jesus fucking Christ.
But you know,
I've been meditating and I guess I'm not supposed to get upset about this.
I should really,
you know,
I should expect it.
I should expect that behavior out of him.
So you're saying that you're hearing these voices in your head or site?
Can I don't,
I'm making up all of this shit.
I couldn't get,
I don't think I got
20 seconds.
30 seconds and do it the second she said the Robin Williams sing and then they
cut to him.
Go.
So your PSI and once he did that,
I had to just,
I shut it off.
Shut it off.
Doctor Phil,
have you no shame.
I swear to God,
that fucking guy.
I'm trying to think what he wouldn't interview,
you know,
what wouldn't you like?
First of all,
I love that people watch those shows is I as if they're like watching somebody
trying to help somebody.
They're not,
you can't fix somebody in a half hour episode
on that time when he had that girl on that little girl on there,
the uh,
you know,
catch me,
I sat my dad,
that one that went fucking viral and then he has her back on again.
He's like,
people thought,
oh,
explored nurse.
Oh,
we took out the studio audience.
Yeah,
but you still broadcasted it.
I Dunno,
but you know something.
I'm a hypocritical cunt.
All right.
Because I still watched the catch me outside.
How about that?
I just kept seeing it on Twitter and I was like,
I have to see what that is.
And I'm not gonna lie to you.
I did watch it and I did enjoy it.
So maybe I got a knock back.
My criticisms,
criticisms,
why don't you just exploit people that still have their whole life ahead of them
?
Okay.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I don't know.
Did I become the asshole by the end of that?
I don't remember.
I don't even,
I didn't know where the fuck that whole thing went.
Um,
so anyways,
I was watching the f one race in Austria,
which by the way,
this,
there's something fucking crazy going on in Austria right now.
Uh,
Jewish people relax.
Um,
it's not that,
um,
well,
it's kind of is,
it's kind of related to that.
Then you,
you know,
in fucking in England,
like all this shit is old because they,
you know,
that's the origins of white people.
And like,
she listened to a nas album and somehow we all came from Egypt,
which they're not really black either,
are they?
They're like Arab,
you know what I mean?
But he's like,
yeah,
they're African.
It's like,
all right,
well I'm German and Irish.
Do I also claim to be Italian because I'm European,
like African as Africa is a continent.
I've never been able to.
So you're say in that we all came from Egypt,
um,
day right now.
There's no fucking way I did.
If you ever saw my fucking legs,
the,
I mean,
I don't know how fucking long ago my ancestors left Africa or how,
and then why we did what we sat in a fucking Snow Jacuzzi fucking 2000 years.
Um,
I dunno,
but I do actually,
I do believe that we all came,
we had to all come from the same fucking,
yeah.
Uh,
whatever lake.
Okay.
Do you know,
you realize what you're listening to right now.
You're listening to a comedian trying to figure out like,
just because he watched like 10 minutes of Neil degrasse Tyson,
whatever fucking name is as he's falling asleep.
And I,
if I can quote de Grasse Tyson,
whatever the fuck his first name is.
Uh,
I believe he thinks we came from trees and I don't mean like we were living in
trees,
like we will apes A's,
no trees.
Like,
yeah,
I don't know.
I,
that was one of those things where I was just like falling asleep.
It's like this fucking guy's crazy.
I fell asleep.
I never saw the other other part of it.
Yeah.
Do you know what the deal is?
You'd go over his house and he convince you of it,
you go over and he'd have on a turtleneck with a sport coat over it,
like smoking a pipe and there'd be a fire in the fireplace,
right?
He'd come in and he'd have all these fucking artifacts,
you know,
you and your wife show up as these other couples there and you just stick in.
Like,
this guy's either going to fucking tell me the secrets of the world or I'm going
to slowly lose consciousness and end up in one of those sounds of the lambs pits
trying to steal his dog.
Um,
anyways,
the fuck am I talking about?
I,
uh,
oh yeah.
So I'm,
I'm why,
Oh,
why?
why,
what happened in Austria?
So what's happening in Australia?
It might already been solved.
I just remember seeing it a little while ago because a couple of weeks ago I was
trying to see where the f one circuit was taking them next.
And uh,
I guess in Austria,
Hitler's house still exists,
like where he was born,
but it's more like an apartment building.
So I guess all these neo Nazis go there and they do like the Neo Nazi,
like yellow Selfie,
Yo,
instead of doing the peace sign,
I bet this,
but you can't do like a full sieg Heil,
you know,
in a selfie.
That's a hard,
your arms aren't long enough to hold it out.
So they probably do it to the side,
you know,
it's just from the elbow to the tip.
And then they do the duck face.
Right.
I guess they'd been doing that.
I don't know what the fuck they're doing.
They're doing some shit like that in front of it.
And for some reason people feel that if you take that place down,
yeah.
That,
you know,
those guys aren't going to continue to exist.
Um,
I don't know about that,
but
okay.
I mean,
what are people going,
you know,
I was going to be in Neo Nazi,
but de ne took down or hit lose fucking buildings,
so whatever.
So there's somebody that owns it and he's like,
Nah,
I'm not tearing this shit down.
And the government's like,
right.
Again,
I'm fucking say's it all right.
That's how they talk in Austria too.
Everybody talks like my bed sort of fucking English accent maybe what?
I don't,
what the fuck it is,
Davy Jones,
whatever I'm doing.
Um,
so there's some big battle about that and they're going to like knock it down.
But I gotta be honest with you,
as much as I'm not down with the Nazi.
So like if I went to Austria,
I would go see that place.
Okay.
I would be like the most evil baby,
Eh,
you know the Jordan of evil babies,
you know,
w fucking came home to that place right there.
Yeah.
People walked in and saw baby Hitler and we're like,
oh,
isn't he adorable?
Look at his eyes is a lot going on in there.
So they want to get rid of that.
Um,
I don't know.
I thought that that was fucking interesting.
Like,
ah,
this is what kills me.
He's like,
who fucking,
how do people know that that's what he grew up.
So many people fucking died in World War II.
You think that anybody that even remotely fucking remembered it,
the old people got,
yeah,
place right down the street.
Always had a funny look on his face.
I never liked him.
Right.
They just passed a story on,
it's too juicy a gossip that it just [inaudible].
It just keeps getting passed down to the point they got to knock down this
perfectly good fucking building.
I guess it needs to be read down a little bit like we're doing with the baseball
stadiums over here,
and then what happens?
They throw it out and ends up in the ocean,
throw it out in the fucking Mediterranean Sea.
That water,
you know the water that when you go over there,
they try to say there's no sharks in them until you go on the Internet.
Is that go?
Yeah.
I just saw there was a couple of attacks.
I am Amy.
There's been a couple of attacks,
but you know that,
you know that's,
it's rare.
Yeah.
Shark attacks in general.
Rare considering most of us are on the fucking land.
I Dunno.
I swam in the Mediterranean.
I absolutely loved it.
It was fucking life changing.
But afterwards,
when I was reading about the shark attacks,
there is just this fucking,
it's the scariest thing other than being tortured,
you know,
I'm trying,
I'm trying to think,
you know,
of stuff equal to that.
Speaking of shark attacks,
I was watching this fucking movie that starred Paul Walker.
Rest peace.
Jessica Alba,
uh,
Scott Conn is other woman.
Her name escapes me.
Um,
I was watching that movie and uh,
I don't know what the fuck it's called.
I don't know what the Fuck's calling Jessica Alba.
First of all.
It's so fucking beautiful.
You just,
it's like she doesn't have to do anything.
He just sits there.
She looks fucking amazing,
Greg.
And uh,
that movie was so fucking ridiculous,
yet entertaining.
I don't think I've ever seen people hold their breath longer underwater in my
life.
You know,
there's a fucking crash plane under the water.
They go down there,
they find drugs.
This is even like a spoiler alert.
This is like how many fucking times they'd done the movie.
We're regular people find a bag of money.
Oh,
they find some fucking drugs.
Ooh.
Should we do I think we should weave it?
No,
you should take it,
man.
Did she show shot?
Right.
And then the fucking bad guys figured out that they fucking took it somehow.
The same classic fucking story,
right?
That Tom Hanks lost his wife and he meets Meg Ryan in Seattle.
It's all the same fucking movie.
Billy crystal comes in and says a couple of things.
Okay.
Then Rom rider makes a cameo cause he's directed in the thing and then somebody
starts shooting up,
Tom Cruise run through in the dubs come up and as you fucking movie,
it's every Hollywood movie.
Somebody is getting too old for this shit.
Uh,
the two people that hate each other have realized that they,
they,
they now love each other.
Uh,
the two photos that look at each other and they realized that,
you know what,
I respect you.
You know,
the days of thunder ending,
I think.
I think that covers it.
All right.
Um,
anyway,
so we'll watch this fucking movie and at one point the bad guys have scuba gear.
Paul Walker and fucking Scott Conn have no scuba gear.
They just dive down to this fucking played.
But you like,
I don't like 20 fucking feet under the water.
So they fucking the scuba guys swimming or the plane looking for him.
Scott Conn is sitting in one of the,
in the copilot seat pretending to be dead.
He had enough time to sit there and gather himself,
pretend to be dead,
holding his fucking breath.
Yeah.
And the scuba guy comes up and looks at him.
He's like,
well I guess he's dead.
And he keeps going and meanwhile they keep cutting the Paul Walker rest in peace
.
Right.
He keeps fucking peaking in little more than the windows and the seat is like
five fucking minutes long.
Real time it feels when you just do it in the math of how long it would take to
get down there,
how long you could fucking stay down there and he's like peaking.
And then he would just duck back out of the way.
And all they had the decency to do is have like one or two little air bubbles go
like,
yeah,
if I'm underwater and I don't have any fucking air,
I mean your heart's already racing like a fucking lunatic.
So eating up that oxygen,
forget about the fact that there's these drug dealers with scuba gear that want
to kill you and you're in shark fucking waters
didn't affect Paul Walker or Scott Conn in the least.
Somehow they were able to throw effective punches under the water I made.
It was,
it was unbelievable the leaps of faith that you had to make in that movie yet I
still enjoyed it,
you know,
cause every time you were like,
this is fucking ridiculous.
They would cut to Jessica Alba just going back,
should we keep the jogs or something?
You got,
oh my God.
It's fucking beautiful.
Genius.
The editing of that movie is genius.
I don't know what it's called though.
There's,
she has one scene.
She just leans against the door brushing your teeth.
It's like I could watch a movie of that.
Jessica Alba gets ready for bed.
Um,
so check it out.
I think that's what that movie is.
It's called something,
something about the Di,
they always called the deep the cove.
I don't know what it was,
but I was just sitting there,
you know,
in my own way,
making fun of the movie,
trying to make Nia laugh.
That was just like jazz gum.
The,
I'm not going to wear a shirt and a z a,
you're going to wear a shirt.
Um,
which is probably childish.
That's what I do here.
Wait a second,
I'm going to find out the other name of that actress on that movie and can't
name three of the four stars.
Right.
Can I hang on a second?
Actually,
you know what?
Fuck that.
I'm not even going to look that up.
I have to give somebody,
I got to give two people a shout out.
Um,
I've been watching bloodline,
I'm up to episode eight,
season three.
I got two more episodes to go that show.
That series is gut wrenching.
Like I can only watch two of them and then I have to shut it off.
And I,
I've never watched the show where I get so mad at the characters,
you know,
I guess so fucking mad.
Like why the fuck did you just do that?
Shut up,
stop talking.
All of that stuff.
Most of it's with the Kevin Character.
MMM.
Norbert Leo Butz,
one of like five people.
Whoever won the best lead male Tony Award.
MMM.
That which is a Broadway Oscar,
basically these amazing fucking actor.
So anyways,
there's a guy on that show who plays Eric O'bannon,
who's absolutely killing it.
His name is Jamie Mcshane.
And for breaking bad fans,
if you're wondering,
well,
how do I know that guy's face?
Why would his face fucking make,
what am I,
how do I know that guy?
If you're a breaking bad fan,
the episode,
I'm not going to give anything away.
The one that involved the train,
all right.
I can't remember.
He played the conductor or the engineer and uh,
he was a great fucking guy in his work on this show is fucking unbelievable.
I Dunno,
I want to quote his lines,
but I want everybody,
like when they watch movies,
it's like years later.
Do you know my dad just saw,
like I did this movie called stand up guys,
and he calls me up.
You like Christ fail.
Yay.
I tell you,
you,
yeah,
the night I'm sitting there,
I'm like,
I'm like narcoleptic I'm falling asleep on the couch.
I wake up at three in the morning and I'm watching this movie and I'm already
laughing cause I know it's gonna be some shit I did like fucking 10 years ago,
you guys,
it's got an output.
Chino and Christopher Walken and I'm watching the movie
and all of a sudden,
there you are.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
He wakes up.
My mother goes,
Jesus Christ.
That's all my parents bed touch into my career.
They watch shit that I did.
It goes,
there was a great movie.
Well,
I'll tell you brilliant all you could do this comedy stuff,
you could do the dramatic shit.
Fucking get it all figured out.
That's what he said.
You could do the dramatic shit.
It's my favorite thing anybody said to me all week.
Yeah,
you could do the dramatic shit.
Um,
so anyways,
two thumbs up from my dad for a,
the fucking standup guys.
Check it out if you get a chance.
Um,
anyways,
Jamie McShane is fucking kill everybody's killing it on.
Yeah,
let's show.
And then also,
uh,
John Leguizamo.
I mean,
has that guy ever been bad at anything?
He's fucking,
everything he's in.
He makes it better.
The guy's fucking unreal.
And
he's like creepy and hilarious all at the same time,
which I don't know how you'd do that unless you're a fucking genius.
Like that guy.
There's a scene.
Um,
uh,
how do I do?
I don't want to fucking ruin it for people.
He goes in and he orders like a,
what we used to call like a slurpee or a frosty,
when one of those see orders,
one of those,
it's one of the funniest fucking scenes I've seen in a long time.
Um,
just start watching bloodline and I'm telling you,
if you want to not have your insides get fucking all twisted up,
just you do two episodes at a time.
Okay.
The first season,
you know,
it's like,
all right.
You know,
it starts a little slow.
Like most series do because they got to establish who the characters are,
what the background is.
But once that fucking Brock starts rolling down the hill,
so I'm going to watch the last two episodes today.
And um,
and I,
I dunno,
you know,
I'm excited to see what happens,
but then I also have that,
like,
I almost had the balls to say this.
I almost had the nerve to say like,
you know,
when you finishing a great book,
like I read,
I remember back in the day when I used to read in a book would end and I used to
read a lot of that was that guy who did all the train spotting and Marabou stork
nightmare books.
I used to read all of his shit,
urban Welsh or something.
Then I started reading the classics.
I remember I read the full version of the three musketeers,
the three musketeers,
the count of Monte Cristo.
Yeah.
It was like 700 something pages of the smallest fucking
typeset or font you've ever seen in life.
And I'm like,
I'm finishing this fucking thing.
And,
um,
I just would try to read like 20 pages a day.
It took me months to finish that fucking book
and,
but I did,
I finished it and I was like,
wow.
Not like I spent a significant part of my life reading this book that's out.
Let's,
how slow I read in all these Vietnam was always proud that I read that book.
I read it like 20 years ago
and I remember thinking like,
you know,
this is what people did back then.
They had time to read books like this because there wasn't the internet,
there wasn't the TV and all that,
and they were bored and needed to be entertained.
So these guys would just spin these yarns that would go for six,
seven,
eight,
900 fucking pages.
And recently,
I forget where I saw it,
they said that Alexander Dumas,
so have you say his name was getting paid by the word
and at 20 years later,
I'm like,
you fucking asshole.
You could have finished that shit.
Like 200 pages.
I read like the director's cut
of the Count of Monte Cristo.
I still love the book that I love a story of revenge,
you know.
So anyways,
this is the time when I would usually read some fucking advertising,
but I'm,
I'm doing this early
because I got shit to do tomorrow.
Um,
I got shit to do tomorrow,
man.
Uh,
I've got stuff to pick up the last few pieces of hardware that I need,
um,
for my kit and then I'm good to go there.
Um,
let's see.
Let's see.
The advertising has not come in yet.
So what do I do now?
Do I just pause here and I just pretend like I have reads to do,
how many minutes have I done?
37,
37 minutes.
You don't,
I'm just going to continue talking about this shit.
I want to,
then I'll just do,
I'll just hit pause and when the advertising comes in I'll read it and then when
the fucking the questions comes in,
I'll fucking read those too.
So anyways,
um,
uh,
so what you're saying is
I saw this thing,
you know,
when I shut off the f one race,
which is kind of becoming my teaser here,
like people used to talk about it.
Are you going to talk about it when I shut it off?
Okay,
well I'll,
I'll talk about the f one race.
Um,
congratulations to,
uh,
I always want to say Valerie Valtteri,
whatever his fucking name is botox.
He had such a good start to start that race.
They actually thought he,
uh,
he,
she was a fucking Cheetah,
like the Indianapolis Colts there.
Um,
and it was a typical fucking f one race where it was the first guy to turn one
won the fucking race.
There was a fucking accident in the beginning,
right?
The guy in the fucking,
the stepchild of the red bull team that that Rojas fucking team,
whatever the fuck,
whatever they are,
Jesus built grab,
I almanac grabbed the fucking program.
If you're going to talk about it,
have a little bit of respect for the people that actually watched the Goddamn
race.
What's the name of their fucking team?
What is it?
Wait,
oh,
the Toro Rosso.
Rossa that fucking lunatic.
He came in and he fucking slammed into one of the Mclaren's who then slammed
into the,
uh,
the red bull guy,
a Max Verstappen and every one of them,
their whole fucking day was over.
That was it.
It was over.
Botox was out in front.
Lewis Hamilton got like a five position,
uh,
I dunno.
Penalty because he had to change his gearbox during qualifying.
So even if he was number one,
the best he could have done was in qualifying was six.
So he was started eighth,
so I guess evidently wait,
there'll be a f five swat.
Yeah.
So I guess he came in third anyways,
um,
pretty uneventful race the whole fucking time,
other than,
uh,
than in the end.
It got great.
But I assume some,
I actually love the shit that Lewis Hamilton was talking.
They were talking about the whole,
uh,
his,
his bullshit with the,
what's,
what's his face there?
Sebastian Vettel.
And uh,
he goes,
you know what he planned to do?
He goes,
you know,
I'll go out there and try to exploit a few of his weaknesses.
Just floats that out there.
So of course the report of bytes it goes,
uh,
what are some of his weaknesses?
Would you say?
A,
his temper is,
uh,
is one of his weaknesses because I guess this guy a valleys,
he's,
he's dangerously approaching 12 penalty points.
If you get 12 penalty points,
you have to sit out a race within a calendar year that basically pet points for
being a cunt,
driving dangerously,
slamming your car in the Lewis Hamilton,
whatever the fuck it is.
He still would,
um,
he's like those people on the highway out here that pass you on the right to at
90.
He does shit like that.
So if you accrue 12 of those points within a calendar year,
you have to sit out a race,
which is devastating,
especially if the guy you're going up against wins the race.
He gets 25 points is just sitting there on your ass,
you know,
sitting on your helmet.
So anyways,
they sent him,
he goes,
I'm exploited a few of his weaknesses.
So the report,
it bites and goes,
this is temper one of them and Lewis smiles,
it goes,
yes.
Which is the perfect thing you want to do with someone with the temper,
you know,
speaking from experience because all that does is make us more mad and then we
fuck up again.
Right.
So then the,
the uh,
the report,
it goes,
well,
what's his other weakness?
And Louis just smiles.
It goes,
he's like,
I'll keep that one in my pocket.
And he walked away and I was like,
ah,
that was perfect.
Perfect.
He's in his head.
Um,
but anyways,
like I said,
it was pretty uneventful for the whole time.
Uh,
everybody just cruising around the fucking track.
Um,
no big crashes after that turn one and,
uh,
bumped the fucking American team.
The highest team was up front for like two laps.
I ain't know they gave us a little pat on the head.
Like we spoiled able to hold off to Ferrari's for the first three laps of a 71
lap race.
And as an American,
I'm supposed to be excited by that is we have the Ferrari junior engine or
whatever the fuck they give us.
Um,
so anyways,
the uh,
the final like six laps,
Rick,
uh,
um,
okay.
Lewis Hamilton was right on fucking Ricardo's ass.
The tires are all fucking chewed up.
I was convinced Hamilton was going to catch him.
Ricardo was able to hold off,
hold them off,
and then,
uh,
Sebastian Vettel was right on.
Botox is asked once again,
no passes were made,
but it was still fucking exciting.
The last six laps of the race was great and that track was fucking cool as hell.
Man,
I love how it starts like uphill.
That bizarre.
I don't mind missing a track laid out like that.
And it's in the,
uh,
the Austrian Alps.
How do you not fucking go to that swing?
Buy Hitler's house.
You go to the f one race and then you get yourself some bean or Schnitzel.
How do you not,
how do you not do that fucking Trifecta?
That's a bucket list thing right there before they tear it down.
I mean,
I was always a fan of the Allmond always.
All those horror movies,
those demon babies.
Do you not fucking go there and just be like,
he fucking learned how to walk in that house.
It's just fascinating.
Like the first time he lost his temper was in that house.
First Time he realized he had an,
he could draw.
I don't know how long you fucking stayed there.
It's just eerie.
You know what I mean?
Look,
if universal studios,
if you can take the tour over there and they still have the fucking,
uh,
the psycho house,
you know,
because everyone just wants to look at that.
This is a real life.
Fucking psycho.
Hey and be glorified.
I'm not glorifying it.
It's the same reason why I want to see a great white shark from a boat.
You know,
I don't fucking,
this is so,
and as much as everybody fucking bitches,
there's no way.
If you walk down the street,
you could,
you couldn't fucking look at it.
You couldn't feel that,
that fucking vibe of evil.
We're coming off the side of the fucking house.
Oh,
they'd probably right.
They should probably take the fucking thing down,
you know?
All right,
well why am I talking about Hitler's house?
Can somebody explain it to me?
So anyways,
the race ends,
I shut it off at coming here to go do the podcast.
And um,
I ended up,
uh,
as when I shut off the race,
this is woman was short hair,
you know,
she's got the fucking,
uh,
the hit,
same haircut is at one who's the girl come in at.
So you better get the party started.
Uh,
bear with
amber,
that pink
right?
He had the pink hair cut and she's sitting there talking to this guy and I'm
looking at it like,
this looks like a fucking therapy session.
What's going on here?
And the show was called the therapist
and they then,
and I'm,
and she's sitting there,
it's Katy Perry
talking
I about herself and like,
yeah,
you know,
some people like me,
so people go solving all like hair long hair,
God.
And I'm just sitting there thinking,
why are you doing this
sweetheart?
You should do this in private.
Why would you put all this shit out of it?
Is she going nuts
but as much you know her,
I felt bad for cause it's just like you,
she's fucking obviously going through some shit,
but [inaudible] fucking therapist guy,
they got this whole intro and he's like walking through doors and shit.
Like I'm just say,
we'd say,
and I'm a licensed fucking therapist.
You're a fucking money grubbing.
Can't.
Okay.
Acting like you try to help Katy Perry Adis shut it off.
I had to shut it off.
I rewound it cause I had to find the,
the,
the name of the fucking show and then I had the fucking walk away.
Jesus Christ.
Katy Perry,
if you need therapy,
go to a fucking therapist.
Close the fucking door.
Havers shut off her phone
then get,
get it out.
And I hope you get better.
You don't fucking do it on TV.
Okay.
Do you realize what you're doing?
Yeah.
You're letting the world know what hurts you and you're on the Internet.
Are you out of your fucking mind?
These are my weaknesses and every fucking asshole on the internet,
it's going to be coming after you.
It's a bad move.
That is not a good move and like debts,
licensed therapist air quote,
fucking that guy.
That guy should be disbarred that you would do fucking exploit something like
that.
But you know what,
the end of the day,
I mean it was probably her people's idea.
She greenlit it and then they had to find,
they had a find a therapist low enough on the rung with enough TV presence that
would fucking agree to do that Gig.
I'm trying to think of this standup equivalent to that.
A televised,
you know what it would be?
It'd be like those fucking gigs at Beyonce and all those guys do for like
fucking New Year's.
They go out,
they sneak out of the country and they'd go do like fuck.
And they sing bootylicious for like 5 million bucks to the son of a fucking
dictator.
You don't want some country that were at odds with,
I guess like the TV version of it.
Maybe.
I don't know who the fuck knows speaking and all that shit.
Did you see when Trump went to Russia,
any bed flicking Vladimir Putin?
Do you see that?
That was fucking hilarious.
You know what?
That's when they fucking was shooting the shit.
It reminded me of Jimmy,
the gent,
Nafta,
the left Swansea,
high solver.
The fuck you said when Trump walked in,
Putin should have been like Camilyo come a Yo
love swans.
Loved.
How do you say l u f t h Lufthansa Heist
model.
I don't fucking know.
Um,
anyways.
Oh,
by the way,
uh,
rest in peace.
Great drama.
Passed away about four days ago.
Jonathon Blackwell,
who uh,
absolutely killed it with prince,
new power generation playboy on Justin Timberlake's big,
I think his first album.
Uh,
that tour,
was it?
Blood sugar,
sex magic?
I can't remember what sexy back tour
I'm stomping on a disco ball,
whatever the fuck it was called.
I can't,
you know,
I actually own the album too.
That's the sad thing.
Wham,
wham,
Bam,
Bam are bringing sexy back.
Right.
And what's that other one?
The other one,
I always get the words wrong and Neil always laugh.
What does that one,
uh,
oh,
I always think he says dirty bitch that I let you with me if you misbehave.
I would say he's going dirty bitch.
And he always laughs God,
he's not saying dirty bitch.
Yeah.
Like,
well,
what's he saying?
She goes a dirty bay or something like that,
you know,
is the hardest one to fucking understand.
Is that a Rihanna?
She got the accent and she doesn't,
uh,
she says like the first three letters of every word at the end of a sentence.
What's,
what's our new fuck it hit we,
you know,
me and Neil will,
I forget what the fuck we were going,
but we add on like pop radio,
right?
I'm gonna pop stations there.
Is that what it's called?
Top 40.
And it was hilarious.
Like they played the same 10 songs on the way there and the same 10 songs on the
way back.
Um,
isn't that,
and then a lag.
Lag.
It wasn't that one,
but it was the same thing.
It began with a w what?
Ours is going to fucking drive me nuts.
I gotta look it up.
All right,
Katie fucking Perry.
Katy Perry.
What a show.
Katie pate.
Not Katy Perry.
Sorry.
Uh,
not [inaudible],
not Jimmy.
The Gent.
Rihanna.
Rihanna
music.
Let's see if it comes up.
My Ella,
Ella
a or e,
come on
loading.
Slowly loading.
I'm running out of shit to talk about.
I might have to fucking hit pause here at this point.
Maybe I can look up the song.
Oh yeah,
the devil did a work.
Work,
work.
No,
it's not that one.
She has a lot of WWE songs.
Don't stop the music.
Work love on the brain
diamonds umbrella.
We found love.
Bitch better have my money.
Okay,
man.
Down.
All right.
This is,
I'm just,
I'm too fucking old to be looking at this shit.
You know what I mean?
God bless you.
God bless.
She hits.
Okay.
I'm going to fucking shoot.
I like being an old guy and you know something.
When you,
when you're fucking old guy,
you got to know when you're too old to be fucking looking at something.
You just walk away.
You know?
Maybe you see like those fucking,
I don't understand why guys over 40 is take those fucking testosterone pills.
It's like you finally clear in your head.
You know what I mean?
You finally getting out of the fucking bars.
You finally really realizing how much more sustained happiness you can get out
of order in a brand new drum kit and set in the fucking thing up.
Then the fucking colossal waste of time that chasing pussy is,
you know,
you see that corner,
you,
you're a guy over 40 try.
Was it new?
Genics
they act like your testosterone dipping is a bad thing.
It's a fucking great thing.
The clouds are finally partic.
Why would you want to take a bottle of that be 18 forever fucking juice?
Jesus Christ.
Do you want to go back into the sports bar?
Shorten up that the fucking sporty slash horror themed waitresses,
right?
The original spice girls does.
They walk around with jerseys tied on.
It's willing to gain.
You want to sit wings?
He wants my buffalo wings.
Is that slowly fucking killing you?
Why would you want to take a fucking pill that's gonna make you think that
that's a good option.
I'm going to go back into that.
You know,
then he got his start p 90 exited.
You got on a myrtle,
right?
A man girdle trying to suck in your fucking,
you know,
guys,
the torso just starts.
It just keeps getting thicker and thicker.
Right?
You got your fuck.
You still get your skinny highschool legs cause you just boozing it up.
You've got that goddamn beer belly.
Now you're going to fucking throw some 18 year old fucking testosterone down
your throat as you're walking up there.
You know,
you gotta die your goatee before you go down there.
And what the fuck are you doing?
Just let it go,
man.
Fuck it.
Jesus Christ.
I will never fucking understand this.
I don't want to go back into that fucking world.
Granted,
I experienced it with an orange Afro.
I mean,
maybe you guys had a better time than I did.
I don't fucking know.
I don't pretend to know.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
I think this is it.
I don't know,
like go any fucking further year.
If I talked about everything that I wanted to talk about.
I believe I have,
oh,
coming up this weekend,
me and Dean del Rey,
host of the,
uh,
let there be talk podcast are going to be at the Fountain Street church in Grand
Rapids,
Michigan.
This is one of my favorite fucking places to play.
It's a a still functioning nondenominational church.
All right.
Which is why they let comedians go in there.
If I ever decide to get back into religion,
um,
I think I could,
you know what?
I bet I couldn't go to a non denomination one either cause they'd be so busy
patting themselves on the back about how open minded they are.
Just whatever you want to do.
If you want to stand,
you want a deal and I can have all the Catholic in me going,
there's gotta be some sort of structure.
Um,
what is this a fucking drum circle anyways,
we're doing two shows Friday,
I think one Saturday or the other way around.
All I know is a third.
The third show is just been added.
There's still some tickets left.
A,
a,
they just added that thing cause the first uh,
did so well.
So thank you to everybody that's showing up.
I can't wait to go up there and run my fucking mouth standing on an altar.
You gotta go to this.
If you don't see me,
you have to see a show at this place just to see the fucking venue that it has.
An upper deck,
horseshoe upper deck that runs from one side of the altar,
right down the hall,
all dump down the side of the fucking,
you know,
the,
the windows there to the back of the church and then comes right back up again
like a horseshoe.
Right.
Like what they still call Ohio State stadium even though they enclosed it.
Um,
and like the altar is like the new stands that they stuck in there when they
enclosed it.
Um,
so I'll be up there and then I go to New York to do the acting gig.
Yeah.
I'm just basically filibuster and right now seeing if I can get the fucking,
Nah,
they ain't coming in.
God Damn it.
They're not coming in.
Um,
I,
when I read some dates for you,
you don't,
not like,
you can't do this on your own
bill.
bird.com.
Stand up dates.
I have got to change the fucking picture.
Oh,
I got one with the shaved head.
I just never fucking,
I got to learn how to upload photos.
All right.
Where do I go here?
Shows.
Yeah.
All right.
This is what I got coming up.
Then I got in August 10th,
Red Bank,
New Jersey.
Count Basie theater.
All right.
And then after that one,
uh,
August 13th,
all things comedy producing their first stand up special ever.
Uh,
Paul Versey.
All right.
Me and Pete Davidson are going to come out on stage and get the crowd warmed up
and then Paul is going to go out and absolutely crush it.
It's taken place.
It's going down at the Tarrytown theater in Tarrytown,
New York.
Absolutely beautiful.
Uh,
bring the wife,
bring the kids,
don't bring the kids.
Uh,
come up there.
Hang out with us.
Watch a great special.
Uh,
tickets are going fast.
Um,
I'm sorry.
August 10th and 11th.
I'm in red bank.
Oh,
and 12th.
Oh Shit.
And then I fucking hang up with Versie.
Bam.
On the 13th.
Um,
August 27th,
Hyannis Massachusetts at the Cape Cod,
melody tent Jode.
Um,
then I'm doing a,
the Hampton Beach Casino first show sold out.
That's on the 30th second show.
The added a late show,
September 2nd.
I'm at Valley Center,
Harrah's resort southern California.
Um,
in September 8th,
I'm at the Horseshoe Casino and Blues Ville,
Mississippi Blues Ville,
Mississippi.
Then I'm going to an Alabama game,
the crimson tide high.
Going to that,
uh,
September 22nd,
I'm at
the Toronto Sony Center,
the Sony Center
in Toronto,
Ontario on the 22nd 23rd.
Then I'm in Vegas on the 29th.
Yeah.
Then on the 6th of October,
I'm in Saint Petersburg,
Florida through the Ma Mahaffey theater.
Now this is what's great about that Gig is the Thursday,
I'm going to see the patriots play the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
That's the last NFL team I need to see
a home game of including the fucking Los Angeles chargers.
But I'll go to one of those September.
Um,
then I do my gig and then the next day I go see that Florida,
Lsu,
Gip.
And on December 14th,
I got the hard rock and um,
in Florida and I might have one overseas gig in Europe in December in my
favorite city over there.
My favorite city did take my wife.
Um,
possibly we're working on it.
We are working on it.
I'm going to hit pause right now.
I'm going to wait for the advertising to come through.
I'm going to read the fuckers,
but it's not going to take any time out of your life cause I'm not doing like,
you know,
not just going to leave a recording,
you know what I mean?
Alright.
I'll see you in a couple hours,
but in your world would be a couple of seconds.
All right,
I'm back.
Goddammit.
I'm back and I am advertising to rake.
Um,
okay.
Pro fucking fly
pro flowers where they were advertising for what's coming up.
Uh,
talk about the reaction you got when you surprise the recipient with pro
flowers.
Bouquets.
Know what?
Nobody,
you know what?
They fucking go.
You know what?
I got the flowers.
I was so thoughtful.
You know what it is?
Everybody that I know that I send flowers,
I send them to them so I don't get to see the reaction.
You know,
I going to start sending it to myself,
you know,
and then you put them behind your back and you just power you take them out.
Then you get to see the surprise.
Predictability is boring,
says pro flowers.
Surprises are exciting,
says proflowers.
Proflowers makes it easy for you to surprise someone right fucking now.
Um,
and it's making it even easier with a special offer for my listeners and whoever
else they advertise with,
send pro flowers,
farmstand flowers and get 20% off of this collection or any other unique
exclusive bouquets of $29 or more.
Pro flowers.com makes choosing the perfect surprise.
Bouquet.
Simple and quick.
Flowers are guaranteed to stay fresh for at least seven days or your money back.
You can get to the flowers last longer than your feelings for the person.
Flowers are guaranteed to stay fresh,
really seven days,
blah,
blah.
You get to pick the exact date you are expected to surprise.
Your surprised will arrive.
Flowers give you more bloom for your buck pro flowers does big beautiful flowers
with more stems.
Few money to get 20% off your birthday.
Fucking flowers or any other bouquet of $29 or more.
Go to pro flowers.com and use my code [inaudible] at checkout.
That's pro flowers.com and code burpee you are are.
Don't wait to make someone's day.
Oh,
go ahead and be unpredictable.
Your goofy self.
You Alright?
Oh,
but okay.
Dope.
[inaudible] gave me some long stem roses.
Bodo [inaudible] beyond ease.
I'll recycle it and give it to Joe to roses.
He's got beady eyes and big fucking glasses.
He goes to the bar.
He's got no classes.
Giotto,
Rosa,
where's me undies?
That's why he's got that goofy smile causes Tate soft left.
What's the,
what's the first thing you put on in the last thing you take off?
It's your underwear.
That's what you do.
Not Use socks.
You fucking Weirdo.
Make your most important piece of clothing the best it can be with me undies.
What is me on these?
You may be asking yourself at your cubicle or possibly your glass office,
Huh?
As you stare at all those people that work for you,
It starts filling up a little bit.
Do you feel powerful?
Um,
oh,
just seriously soft.
Feel good undies delivered right to your front door.
Me undies are designed in La and made from sustainably sauced micro modal,
modal fabric,
three times softer than cotton.
Mandy.
Softer than soft lugs undies luxurious.
What is Lux?
He mean
luxurious underwear come in and ever changing selection of classic colors to
dress your Dick in bold shades and adventurous patterns so you can tailor your
balls,
tail your undies to your own personal style.
And guess what?
You can save time and money each month with a monthly subscription,
monthly subscription.
How much do you shit yourself?
And if you're not ready for a subscription,
that's okay.
You can still save.
That's because me undies is offering you 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL,
me,
undies.com/burr and 20% off your first pair.
I never realized how perfect a monthly subscription is.
If you suffer from anal leakage,
if you eat those Doritos that don't make you fat and some I'll give you abs.
But the one side effect is anal leakage.
Remember that shit?
You know,
what was that?
What Brandon Derita was that Doritos?
I don't know what it was.
I think the flavor was cool.
Mist or something.
This is perfect.
You got a subscription of Biondi so go ahead.
Revamp your underwear drawer.
Let your ass leak.
You deserve it.
Once again,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash bar me
undies.com/burr oh jolly shave club.
Dollar Shave Club is this matter of choice.
You get a great shave at a great price,
conveniently delivered right to your fucking front deal.
You no longer have to Schlep to this store.
Jesus Christ by a cheap disposable razors standing behind some fucking old lady
trying to develop pictures from a camera.
No one's even seen before.
Or you can just join up.
Um,
but dollar shave club and when you use the dollar shave club executive razor
with tucked the cabbies,
easy shave butter,
the blade gently glides across giving you a smooth shave.
Dr. Carver shave butter is transparent,
just like your relationships for a more precise shave helps prevent ingrown
hairs and fights.
Razor bumps,
right.
They have white guys all the way to black guys and grown hairs to raise a bumps.
Make the smart choice by joining Dollar Shave Club.
Any of the last day I tell,
well,
joy dollar shave club for a limited time,
new members can get their first month of the executive razor with a tube of
they're doing too cute for only $5 with free shipping.
After that race was just few bucks a month,
she and you're in the clear,
that's a $15 value for only five bucks.
There are no hidden fees and no commitments cancel anytime you like,
you can only get this exclusive offer,
a dollar shave
club.com/bird that's dollar shave
club.com/burr upside.
Everybody upside down,
boy,
you turn me and sad out ramp.
All right,
upside your fucking turned to me.
There's a better way for you to buy business travel.
It's upside.com,
upside.com.
Every time you buy a trip at upside,
you'll save your company a ton of money and they give you an Amazon gift card
worth hundreds of dollars upside at upsides able to do this because they bundle
your flights and hotel together.
I just picks you're flying with chickens and hold tight for one low price
bundling prices,
save monies,
uh,
saves monies.
If you're a frequent flyer business,
travel,
your company saves a ton of money and you get thousands of gift,
thousands a year and gift cards don't Jay,
when you're a frequent flyer and all those other cons who aren't lineup up and
you got to walk around them like they're trying to draw an offensive foul,
but for whatever reason they're facing the basket,
you want to give them a forum.
Shivah um,
if you're a frequent flyer business,
travel,
your company saves a ton of money and you can get thousands a year and gift
cards just for buying your air and hotel together@upside.com bitch,
turn me plus just you still get your all your miles.
If you're shopping for business travel,
you'd be crazy not to check out upside.com upside doc.
It takes just three minutes to see how much you save by buying your flight.
We get it.
It's fucking amazing and right now when you use my name,
Berbee B u,
r.
R,
you're guaranteed to get at least a $100 Amazon gift card for your first trip.
That's my name.
[inaudible] to get at least $100 Amazon Gift Card for free,
save big on travel and get to get big gift card every trip.
Um,
I love upside.com.
You know,
I just like saying the name,
upset.com you're turning me minimum purchase required.
See the site for complete details.
Oh look who's here are old friends.
Lastly,
but not leastly stamps.com stamps saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business.
I can mail any letter,
any package using just my computer and printer.
Then the mailman comes and picks it up for the hassle of the post office mail.
Everything from postcards to envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps.com account in minutes online with no equipment to lease and
no longterm commitments.
Click print mail and you're done.
Fuck.
You don't need to lease an expensive postage meter.
I use stamps.com because?
Because they fucking pay me to say it
now.
Anytime I have posters then I'm going to whore myself afterwards and sell on
myself.
I,
you know,
sent him out through stamps.com I'm a fucking moron if I can figure it out.
So can you,
and right now you too can enjoy stamps.com servers with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without a longterm
commitment.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone at the top of the home page.
Type in birth that stamps.com enter rubber stamps.com never go to the post
office again.
All right,
we're done.
Nao We're under the questions.
Alright Norway,
when are you coming to Norway?
Man,
we would love it man,
when we need it.
Before we ended,
ended up like Sweden.
Have a nice weekend and go fuck yourself.
He's trash and sweet and Nia.
People want to know when I'm going to come to Norway.
Oh,
is it Nia plus one my
plus one.
There you go.
Little Baby Boo bear there.
Here you go.
You can't sit in that chair right there.
You didn't even entertain that option.
All right,
upset down.
You're turning me.
Give love.
Instinctively rounding.
I was talking about deep into the Blue Ocean with Jessica Alba and Paul Walker
into the blue.
Into the blue.
Oh her hell blue.
That racist ass moving ocean racist.
Yes.
How is it racist?
I watched it as a white person and I didn't have a problem with any of it.
That's a prize.
The prize.
What did you see?
No,
that scene where they had the talk into the Mike for the love of Christ.
You know what?
People have tweeted me and I've been like,
we can hear you just fine.
Well then they would say that I was too fucking loud.
I mean,
yeah,
but they haven't.
They're used to it by now.
All right,
I'm talking to the microphone now.
There was this one.
So this place,
this movie takes place in The Bahamas.
Right.
But of course,
you know,
there's like barely any black people in it and it's white people on vacation.
They're not on vacation.
They live in work that are,
except for Jessica Alba's not white.
Oh right.
Oh Shit.
Now who's not being racially sensitive?
Yeah,
she's,
yeah.
Okay,
fine.
She's not white,
but they're in The Bahamas.
That's our black people live anyway.
Can I finish telling you how I,
you know,
anyway,
one of the guys that either works for them or works with them in some capacity,
he has like maybe two lines and one of them is I gotta go,
my baby Mama is hassling me over a weave or like needs me to give her money for
a week full needs a new,
we've like,
what the fuck they were capturing the uh,
the black experience.
No,
no,
no.
They can't get him aligned to have any kind of like dignity.
Like,
oh,
I gotta go.
I told my wife I'd watched the baby,
or Oh,
I gotta go,
my son has a soccer game.
My Baby Mama needs a weave.
That is so racist.
That is so,
and then,
and then there's another scene where there's somehow explaining,
I dunno,
pirates or some kind of behave,
Ian Legend that you know,
Paul Walker is explaining and then,
um,
what's his name?
Scott Conn is looking at pictures and he's like,
Scott Love Scott.
So this is snoop dog here and these are all his hose and this is pimp cup and
Blah Blah Blah.
And it's like,
really?
He used to be in a rap group.
He knows the terminology.
You know why c eight mile that was based on him and it was based on m and M and
I'm not even one of those white guys.
Scott Conn in a rap group.
Like I'm just not even no less.
I don't even want to talk about that.
Scotty cone.
Oh,
did he scratched to that?
Right.
And he came out.
Oh my,
yeah.
Got,
he goes ridiculous.
The one for you.
One thing that I liked about that movie,
I can't believe we actually watched the whole thing,
but there was a scene,
I enjoyed it.
It was.
So Scott Kahn and Paul Walker are talking about the like,
what are we going to do man?
And the underwater holding their breath or they're above hunching sharks on land
and it's daytime as they're talking and the camera slowly pans around them like
really slow and by the time it's done the son has said and it was a really
beautiful shot.
Other than that,
that movie you can go kick rocks,
right?
Oh that's cause you're holding the baby kick rocks can kick rocks or the f word
in front of her.
We really try not to do that.
No,
I mean,
but that movie was ridiculous and I really upset at that line.
It still bothers me.
Yeah.
I gotta go.
My Baby Mama needs new weeds.
They want under water for 15 minutes.
Like I can suspend my disbelief on that.
That wasn't something that I can just say it.
I mean if,
if they're going to handle why even making excuses for this,
that line in that movie,
because am,
why are you making excuses?
I meditate now and what I've learned to do with anything,
I'm learning to have patients,
patients with what?
With just people's behavior.
While you lucky that you have that ability to do that,
I was very offended and annoyance
by that.
No,
I'm just saying that like if you give them that line,
not to me.
I'm white.
What?
I'm not asking about you as a way
[inaudible] my head did offend you.
I'm just saying I didn't get it.
I'm telling you what it is,
so why are you sending your acting brand new like you don't understand what I'm
talking about?
God,
they,
I'm just trying to be fit.
Some pointed that's not funny.
Well,
I don't care about it being funny.
I know it's a ridiculous fucking lie,
but I got to keep the comedy going.
This isn't counterpoint coin coin.
Oh,
counterpoint.
What is it that we of point you got to more for a host?
Yeah.
Keep the funny for the love of God.
Please.
Let's not lose the funny,
God forbid you actually agree with me on some shit and try Nazi you.
You pitch this episode to be your white people for me.
Good Lord.
I got it.
It's fucking offensive.
I'm agreeing with you.
I'm trying to fucking keep it funny on some level.
Fine.
I'm fine.
I'm just playing the ignorant white guy.
You don't have to play at anything.
Nia.
I'm the one who said the line first.
I was,
I was laying there I go,
I gotta get my baby Mama.
Oh,
we've terrible.
It's terrible.
Writing and making the whole thing.
What the fuck?
It's offensive.
It's fucking people jumping or they're walking around all naked.
Look good.
Holding their breath for fucking four hours.
Do you honestly think that that they're gonna have Maya Angelou or was one of
those people and then fucking hedge?
Is that the right reference?
I'm sure.
All right.
What else you got?
Um,
I dunno.
Okay.
Norway.
When,
when are you on this?
Appalled by the way.
You know what a stupid is?
When I was imitating Jessica Alba doing lines,
I'm like,
eh,
she's dumb.
She's going to billion dollar fucking company.
Where do I get off saying that?
Although my podcast is doing pretty well.
Go on Itunes,
right?
Norway,
when are you
coming to Norway,
man,
we love it.
We would love it and we,
before we end
up like Sweden,
have a nice weekend and go fuck yourself now you man,
we traveled.
You know what that means before we end up like Sweden?
Yeah.
You know what that means?
I don't know what you don't remember when they said Sweden.
Sweden used to,
you know,
Sweden remained neutral during World War II.
Okay,
okay.
And they looked the other way and they allowed the Nazis to use their train
system to go into Norway and fuck Norway up.
Is that what's going to happen?
To know?
Oh,
okay.
Norway had right before the war regained the lower third of their company
country from Sweden.
As soon as like whatever,
we didn't want it anyways or whatever.
Right.
So then they,
during World War Two,
Sweden remained neutral.
Okay.
Let the Nazis go through the Nazis fucked up.
Norway.
Sweden became a power after World War II,
just simply for the fact that their cities were still standing and they could
function as function in like a,
in a business capacity.
Jesus,
I'm using some pretty impressive words for me,
right.
So long story short,
Norway ends up finding in no way didn't offer any,
I mean,
Sweden didn't offer in Norway,
are you helping me and stuff.
Long story short,
no.
Ended up discovering all this oil in that land that they got back,
I believe or northern that,
oh,
that now they make it so much money over there.
Nobody wants to do like lower level jobs.
So Swedes come in and do the jobs.
Norwegians don't want to do.
You don't remember the Norwegian saying,
Oh,
the Swedish people saying,
yeah,
we're like
the Mexicans Fund for Norwegians.
Wow.
Okay.
You don't remember that?
No,
I don't remember that at all.
When would I have,
when was that?
When the guy said it to us,
we flied thought it wouldn't the Norwegian guy,
when we were in Norway,
I gotta be honest with you and you're probably going to jump all over me.
But when we did Norway,
Finland and sweet,
like I honestly can't,
I don't know.
I don't recall which was which country?
Cause it looked the same.
You realize?
Do you realize?
No,
don't try to cover your tracks.
Don't try to cover your tracks.
Do you realize if you took me to Rwanda,
uh,
fucking a Honda.
Ecuador.
And what is the other one over there?
You took me three African countries,
right?
The Gambia,
Gambia Fucker,
South Africa.
And then we went to Rwanda as I gay.
You know,
to be honest with Ya.
Ya,
Ya.
I know what you say.
There's a bunch of blue eyed,
blonde haired white people.
It looked the same.
Norway,
Finland and what was the other one we went to?
What was the other one?
I wouldn't go.
I let it go.
You wish a plane ticket cost me sweet and I love cars.
I love Stockholm.
But what were the other three?
I don't know.
Why don't you go get a fucking globe and spin it around a couple of times?
Figure it out.
I can't remember which country was which.
I always wanted to travel as a little girl.
Hey,
here's three was asked where we had that crazy meal that like 10 course meal,
like the never ending with the cheese at the end with that Norway.
Oh,
why don't you just move out to Calabasas and knock on the Kardashians door right
now?
Why don't you just do that and just fit in with them?
What does anything that I'm saying have to do with the card has plos and
we the cheese.
Remember what Finland versus Norway,
like what we did because they were geographically very similar.
All right.
I'm going to have to do,
I'm going to have to remind you of these places in a way that your little travel
brain little travel can remember.
Okay.
All right.
Finland was where you've got the coat?
Yes.
Okay.
I'm okay now.
You remember that?
Norway's what?
You got the cheese?
Yep.
Okay,
great.
Stockholm you loved,
so you remember that.
There you go.
That's the difference.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
so Finland is the coat country.
Got It.
Oslo's the cheese.
The meal.
Yeah.
We had that 200 course meal.
And then there was that,
the funkiest cheese ever and I was eating it.
You were telling me to stop and my eyes were watering and yeah,
before you told me to stop,
the more I had to eat it because it was funny to me.
All right.
It was cold.
I remember it being cold.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Paris was the place that had the arch like in Washington Square Park.
Yes.
I remember parents restaurant doesn't accept cash,
dear.
Oh dear.
Billy.
Red tits restaurant.
And somebody said this is backwards,
so it's restaurant doesn't accept cash dear while.
One word,
Billy red tits.
I think it's Billy read tits restaurant doesn't s dear Billy red tents.
All right.
The other day I went to a very trended solid place in Hollywood.
Didn't when I went to,
when I say sorry,
trended.
Oh,
very trendy salad place in Hollywood and when I went to pay,
I held out a $20 bill and the cashier said,
sorry,
we don't accept cash.
That's the most ridiculous thing ever.
Have you heard this before?
Yeah.
I'm like trains,
planes and shit.
Planes.
I don't think they do.
What do you think?
Uh,
we have that working towards a cashless society.
We're all gonna be microchipped and that's going to be it.
And right when they gained control of all human society,
the robots are gonna take over.
All right.
Lastly,
but not leastly the last question here.
Girlfriend wants me to call her daddy during sex.
That isn't new one.
Uh,
hey bill.
I just started seeing this girl we'd been dating for about two to three weeks.
She smack attractive.
Everybody says this career driven and generally speaking has her shit together.
She seems like a girl.
She seems like a girl that just seems like a girl as far as I could tell.
She got all the lady parts that I could see myself having a longterm
relationship with.
However,
recently when we were having sex,
sex,
she insisted on calling me daddy.
I've never been the type to talk dirty all.
Oh,
I see.
Okay.
I get it.
Oh,
okay.
I thought it was the other way around.
I thought she wanted you to.
Okay.
Okay,
I see now.
All right,
well that's pretty pedestrian.
Okay.
However,
recently about Predella de,
I've never been the type to talk dirty because it seems kind of silly and takes
me out of the moment.
Yeah,
you guys are not compatible if she's gonna want to sale is filthy crazy over the
top shit and you're going to be like,
oh,
like in your fucking ci,
whatever the fuck you,
you know,
which neither one of you are wrong.
I don't know if you're compatible here.
When she started calling me Daddy,
I was caught off guard but tried to play through it because I didn't want to
make her feel weird when you're a good person then all right.
Now even attempted to throw in my own lines like,
oh yeah,
you like that.
But afterwards,
after the words left my mouth,
I had to try not to laugh because it felt like I was in a cheesy porno and it
started to affect my performance.
Um,
after what she asked me how I felt about it,
and I just brushed it off like it wasn't a problem.
But on the inside I was starting to have my doubts and trying to paint a picture
without giving too much detail because I know you get all the Weirdos,
you get all weirded out by shit.
But I don't know.
I don't get weeded out by a lot of shit.
Uh,
is it weird that she likes me to call her daddy?
Am I walking into relationship with underlying daddy issues?
Helped me out.
Bill,
what should I do?
Oh,
I get to be doctors.
Bill.
Um,
so where do you use Howard Sachs?
Will you all,
she wants you to call her daddy.
This is our doctor.
Phil would handle it.
Yeah.
Well,
um,
most of our fan base is female.
So you're the male in your,
therefore always wrong.
Um,
no,
I would definitely bring it up to her.
Yeah,
I will bring it up to,
it's difficult to bring up something like that with somebody,
but if it bothers you,
you got to bring it up.
I would bring up.
Just say,
listen,
um,
I'm not judging you or anything like that,
but for me,
you gotta,
you gotta keep an eye on us,
your side of the bed.
It just feels weird.
Now how do you say it?
I don't feel comfortable having you call me daddy in bed.
It just,
it makes just say uncomfortable.
Don't say weird.
And then,
Hey Nia,
I need you to help.
Oh,
oh,
you're here.
Keep coming.
I got the go in the other room.
All right.
This guy,
this guy's with this girl who thinks she's great and everything she wants.
She wants a him the call,
she wants to call him daddy during sex and it weirds them out.
How does he bring it up without making her feel like she's got a fucking
problem?
I don't want you to call me daddy during sex because it makes me uncomfortable.
Okay.
I don't think it's wrong.
I'm not judging you,
but just for me.
For me,
that was perfect.
Yeah,
just be honest.
There you go.
But just say,
I'm not trying to judge you.
I don't think you're weird cause I know a lot of people do it cause a lot of
people do do it.
But just I,
it makes me uncomfortable and I'm not ready to go there just yet.
Can we come up with something else left?
They went different language.
Like she I papi.
Yeah.
Well you just picture some completely random language.
Uh,
I is German.
Random enough German now.
You don't have to go there next to him.
She's taking a shit in your chest.
I don't know buddy.
You got a uh,
yeah.
Uh,
however Nia just said it.
That's perfect.
All right,
I'm going to wrap up the podcast here.
that's the podcast.
Everybody.
Thank you for listening.
Thank you guys once again for watching efforts of family.
We've got,
I don't know,
you never know what the fuck ratings you get on Netflix,
but you know,
they gave us another season so they go,
um,
I really appreciate it.
That's it.
Um,
please come out and see me and Dean del Ray at the Fountain Street Church.
Grand rapids added a third show.
Tickets are hopefully going fast,
but hopefully there's some left so you can get them.
Cause I'm saying this some left.
All right,
that's it.
I'll talk to you and check in on you on Thursday.
Bye.